hey everyone I'm Jerry and I'm Gideon
and today our producer has challenged us
to turn this Popeye's Chicken Sandwich
into a sweet dessert our friend Tucker
is going to come in try our dishes and
then we're gonna try to have him guess
what the original dish was are you ready
for the challenge kids always let's do
it let's do it
so my game plan is I'm gonna turn this
into a maple bacon donut first things
first I'm going to be saving this Mayo
for our white chocolate ganache now I'm
going to tear these buns apart now we're
going to toast these and we're going to
grind it and turn them into breadcrumbs
and by toasting these it actually
intensifies the flavor of the bread
because it gets rid of the water and
it's going to enhance the flavor of our
donut all right now that our buns are
nice and toasted and it's cooled down
now we're going to make fine bread
crumbs
all right now this looks perfect and
we're going to use this for a donut
batter so after seeing the Popeye
sandwich I think I'm going to make a
strawberry balsamic cupcake so to kick
things off I'm going to first add sour
cream some milk and vanilla and then
give this a really quick whisk just to
incorporate all of the ingredients and
once that's all mixed I'm going to take
the bun and then break it up into little
pieces first and then I'm going to use a
fork to really really get it into the
wet ingredients this is my first time
turning a Savory dish into a sweet dish
and I'm really curious to know what
Gideon's doing but honestly I'm feeling
pretty confident about this and then
from here I'm going to move on to my dry
ingredients now we're going to make the
candied pickles the first things first
we gotta rinse it all we have to do is
mix water sugar and once that's mixed
then we'll toss the pickles so we're
just gonna let this sit until it becomes
like a super light brown then we take it
up these look great we're gonna let this
set for about 10 minutes so that they
hardened hopefully Tucker doesn't think
it's too weird because I want to win I'm
going to mix into my cake flour some
baking soda baking powder and salt and
then from there I'm just going to give
this a really good whisk just to make
sure all of the dry ingredients are well
incorporated then I'm going to move on
to creaming my butter and whip that on
high for two minutes until it's creamy
light and fluffy about now I'm going to
add the sugar and then beat that for
another two minutes until it's nice
Incorporated super fluffy all right
things are looking good in here we're
going to add three egg whites to the
sugar mixture this is looking so good
I'm going to add my burger mixture to
these wet ingredients here the last step
is to add my dry ingredients to this
give it one last mix and we're good to
go with the batter this is looking
beautiful and I'm going to fill these
just about three quarters of the way up
I'm going to bake these until they're
nice and puffy or when a toothpick
inserted comes out clean all right now
we're going to make our dough first
we're going to mix our wet ingredients
which is buttermilk three egg yolks one
whole egg grape seed oil and lemon zest
we're gonna whisk it now for our dry
ingredients cake flour sugar now the
bread crumbs that we made baking powder
baking soda salt cinnamon and Nutmeg now
I'm gonna mix it for a couple seconds to
mix the dry ingredients we're gonna
slowly add our wet ingredients so we're
going to keep mixing this until it's
well combined it's going to be sticky
but once it's chilled it's going to be
easy to work with now it's time to roll
our dough I have this baking sheet lined
with parchment paper I'm a little
worried because I'm not that experienced
in making donuts you shall see okay so
it's very sticky we're gonna use another
parchment paper so we're gonna roll this
to about half an inch thick we're going
to chill this for about 30 to 60 Minutes
hopefully it'll be easier to work by
then once it's nicely chilled so for
this next part of the cupcake I'm going
to be taking the fried chicken and then
create a crispy chicken buttercream
frosting now I know that sounds super
wacky but just hold tight it's going to
be amazing so here I'm just going to
remove the batter and try to keep the
actual chicken part intact all right now
look at that beautiful I'm going to be
setting this aside and then transfer
this over to my prepared baking sheet
and then I'm going to just pop this in
the oven just for a little bit just so I
can dry it out a little bit more to get
it super crispy so in my next step I am
going to give this a really good chop
and get the pieces nice and fine listen
to that crunch you know Gideon's my boy
he is the Crispy Chicken King but you
know what I'm bringing my game I'm
bringing my game we're gonna move on to
assembling the rest of the buttercream
so starting off I'm going to first cream
the butter and here we have the Mayo
from the chicken sandwich and that is a
lot of Mayor this is so wacky because
I've never added Mayo but I'm super
excited to see that's going to turn out
I'm curious to know how Tucker is going
to feel about having Mayo in his
buttercream frosting and I don't know if
I want to tell him I'm going to whip
this on medium high until it's light and
creamy and fluffy this is looking
beautiful so we have some Vanilla some
heavy cream and then finally some
powdered sugar so I'm going to need
about four cups of this but I'm gonna
add it in little batches just so it
doesn't get messy in here oh
all right okay it's looking beautiful
the last step is adding the super crispy
chicken breading to the frosting I'm
just gonna mix this until the breading
is well incorporated into the frosting
so this last step is transferring it to
a Piping Bag and then I'm going to set
it aside for later now that our Dilla
has been nice and chilled and it's easy
to work with we can start cutting them
I'm going to sprinkle some flour I'm
gonna spray the baking sheet with just
some oil now we have our donut cutter
we're gonna dip that into the flour oh
there we go that's nice I'm just gonna
push it out with my finger nice and
gently we're just gonna let this chill
for 30 minutes then we start frying
about a minute and a half per side until
it's golden brown then we're going to
turn them all right now I'm just going
to fry up the rest chicken floss I'm not
gonna lie I am taking a huge risk with
this I've had pork floss I've even had
fish floss but I've never made my own so
I'm going to rinse this under warm water
just to remove any excess grease so now
that I rinse my Popeye's Chicken I'm
going to add the raw chicken breast
along with the Popeyes Chicken together
along with some water and poach it so
the chicken has been cooking for about
25 minutes it's it's time to shred it so
I've transferred the chicken over to
this tray but I want to hold on to this
liquid for later the chicken has cooled
for a few minutes I wonder if Tucker is
going to be like what is that what all
right y'all chicken is fully shredded
I'm going to add it back to the reserved
liquid along with some salt and sugar
and then reduce that so I'm cook this on
high heat for 15 minutes until the pot
is completely dried out look at what
I've created this is straight chicken
floss oh my gosh
okay now it's time to make the ganache
all we're going to do is mix heavy cream
the Mayo we saved earlier and white
chocolate we're just gonna mix this and
we're gonna microwave this on high in 20
to 30 second intervals until the
chocolate's melted now for the chicken
we're gonna cut this into thin strips
we're just going to toss maple syrup and
brown sugar until they're coated evenly
so we're gonna bake this for about three
minutes per side until it's nice and
caramelized and look like bacon the
Popeye's chicken sandwich has bread and
butter pickles so what I'm going to do
is turn it into a strawberry jam to a
saucepan I'm going to add some cut up
strawberries I chopped up these bread
and butter pickles from the sandwich
some sugar and lastly balsamic vinegar I
know you're probably like are you
serious balsamic vinegar pickles
strawberries strangely enough it's like
a happy marriage of all of these
ingredients I promise Next Step I'm
going to make balsamic strawberries so I
hope Tucker likes strawberries because
it's like strawberries on strawberries
on strawberries with fried chicken I'm
going to add strawberries sugar balsamic
vinegar and lastly corn syrup so I'm
going to mash up the strawberries just a
little bit and this will really help
release some of the juices I'm going to
use this immersion blender and just
blend it until it's smooth look at that
just look at that it's beautiful so I'm
going to let this cool for about 15 min
15 minutes my strawberry glaze is
completely cooled now I'm going to take
the raw strawberries dip them in the
glaze and then let them rest here on
this rack just to let any excess glaze
kind of drip to the bottom I'm going to
set these to the side for 30 minutes and
then we are ready to assemble the
cupcake
now we have our Popeyes chicken bacon
candied pickles mayonnaise ganache and
burger bun donut time for assembly I'm
gonna dip our donut in the ganache now
we're just gonna garnish it with our
chicken bacon and our candy pickles now
here we have it our Popeyes chicken
sandwich donut now I'm gonna finish
decorating the rest because why should
Tucker be the only one to taste this we
have our burger bun cupcakes our bread
and butter pickle and strawberry jam our
chicken floss our crispy chicken mayo
buttercream and last but certainly not
least we have our beautiful [ __ ]
strawberry balsamic garnish so I'm just
gonna give it just a little little
insert right there and then next I'm
going to get my crispy chicken mayo
buttercream look at this it's just it's
beautiful then we have these beautiful
balsamic glazed strawberries I am most
proud of this last step just the teas
for Gideon to let him know that I won
this I won this Tucker's gonna choose
this baby right here this is for you
this one looks like it has rope on top
is this rope edible okay and then here
we have oh my
a pickle sliced so thinly I can see
through it I trust both of these chefs
with my life so I'm just gonna go really
in hard ah okay am I getting cream
cheese frosting am I getting cream
cheese frosting
this thing is going to be the key to me
figuring this out I don't think I'm mad
at it I don't think I'd take a bullet
for it either we're gonna let that
marinate while I come over to this bad
boy oh my God I'm getting like chicken
and waffles what was that pickle there
okay I wonder if Tucker is going to be
like what is that what what they're both
Reckless deep this is like your classic
waffle with the syrup but this one is
you went to IHOP and you said give me
that Tutti Frutti fresh and fruity oh my
gosh this is really hard isn't it chefs
please come in hello what's happening
here I'm dying to know who's the winner
okay this is extremely hard oh and I
think I have to go with this one only
because
only because I love that jerky crunch
with this I think I'm giving it to
Gideon what is the dish before we reveal
one last guess of the original dish I'm
saying Fried Chicken and Waffles give it
to me Goods
hello a Papa's chicken sandwich 100. you
are lying to me right now really never
have I ever had one a hot dog I would
order both of your things again 100 and
that buttercream that you had was like a
crispy chicken skin and mayonnaise why
did I lap that up like a dog
thank you for watching from Savory sweet
and if there are any Savory Foods that
you want us to turn into Sweet Treats
let us know in the comments I have one
Crunchwrap Supreme just an idea bye
everyone thank you so much
foreign